you know I've been a serial omean born
in London there's water found in there
is that the diaspora want to help one to
get involved in hopefully the Cibola
crisis we spoke about Syria load in
there but we also spoke about Guinea who
spoke about a Liberia it's a very much
West African coalition my role is
essentially to be the messenger if you
like or to be a member of the message in
a member of the media there are tools
that I can use that will be effective in
trying to educate as quickly as possible
on the ground in this area I was so
encouraged in there today there is a
room full of people that a task force
see really on their task board the High
Commissioner was there and we were all
talking the same language is what can we
do quickly we will realize the urgency
of this but how can we pull together as
a country quickly and be effective it's
the second time this week I think you've
been involved your other United Nations
I think earlier this week tell us what
you were doing there I was at the United
Nations dr. Navarro was instrumental
invited me to that conference again as a
beacon for Syria to understand that
there is constant media attention it's
nice to be in the movie star it's nice
to be a film stop it if I can use that
to keep the media's attention on what's
going on as a worldwide crisis as we
know that's been the case in America now
and it seems like
you jumped up on that and insured
because this could very quickly be a
worldwide problem but I think we're
going to contain it and especially for
the West Africa not only containment of
our strengthen you know the possibility
of future outbreaks and the Ebola but
other diseases and hopefully put
together a system where would you
respond quicker to a lot of people with
people like yourself with family there
feel powerless in many ways to to help
out when they see all these terrible
reports absolutely you know there's a
sense that you know there are so many
people that feel hopeless but they can't
go back to Syria no no can but how do
they you know connect with their loved
ones but this far are very aware of that
but we're reaching out you know what if
my messaging is to help rent more people
from Sierra Leone and others to come
cereal and help especially you know
people with a health profession it's a
hard ask to ask anybody to go to Syria
there will be a problem there or not but
you know that's part of the message and
we need help urgently